I mean you can see the scores I mean
they're up and read it was anything him
mama June shares her weight-loss surgery
scars with et cameras and reveals the
hardest part of shedding nearly 300
pounds a lot of scarring I'm sure there
should be no I said I mean you can see
the source I mean they're up and read it
was a named Jim sugar he can't see
anything right here no not at all um
served the breast around my own pool
well not the 37 year old says her body
transformation has motivated her to lead
a healthier lifestyle but she still got
her cheat meals my favorite time to like
she I mean I have to say is probably
what Mother Nature hits when you have
New Year's your sweets and my thing is
little Debbie's during that week and so
out there like it was in the boss'll
Debbie's I mean I'm not gonna sugarcoat
anything anybody I mean you know if it
was oh you know you get to be straight
your trigger dad I'm like I promise you
I'm not eating salads every day you're
not but I'm not also eating fried foods
and eating out what would you say was
the hardest part of this entire journey
having to be naughty
no grocery store strips no um store no
school
nothing did you have to walk around in
disguises skies will the worse like
glasses like a hoodie and yes or none
sometimes a week and I'm like worn out I
mean the more the size you do we're
gonna notice you more exactly
you